je suis comme vous et moi je suis un fan
afin de pouvoir depuis depuis ces gamins
mais depuis la première heure elle est
dire qu on était gamin il ya deux
légendes qui tourne autour de bouvard
deux interviews devrait savoir la vérité
exacte c'est mireille mathieu est ce que
c'est vrai cette histoire que vous
auriez remis à johnny stark
à l'époque le questionnaire vallier
poser comme à mireille mathieu et qu'au
dernier moment vous avez changé l'ordre
des questions et qu'elle a répondu avec
une question de décalage comme dans
toutes les légendes il ya du vrai et du
faux vrai c'est que le tonton de génie
qu'était un imprésario comme on n'en
fait plus un jeu te dire ne laissant
rien au hasard m'avait demandé de
communiquer mes questions à l'avant ce
qu'on ne fait jamais du anthologique
mans mais compte tenu de la jeunesse de
mireille et de la sympathique elle
inspirée à tout le monde moi le premier
j'ai accepté j'ai donné les les
questions ensuite qu'est ce qu'il a fait
le tonton johnny il a engagé un
dialoguiste et pas n'importe lequel pour
faire les réponses puis une fois que le
dialoguiste a livré ses réponses il a
demandé à la petite mimi d'apprendre les
réponses et la petite mimine la mémoire
mais mais mais faire en plusieurs
langues
et puis ben on enregistrait sa à londres
mais en français et j'ai posé la
question numéro un est la feue la
question du mais la tranche numéro un
la question numéro deux réponses numéro
2 et à partir de là la machine s'est
complètement détraqué est ce à dire j'ai
posé la question numéro 3 et qu'elle a
fait la réponse numéro 4 et tout a été
décalé voilà c'était pas notre faute
mais c'est pas du tout y avait aucune
chanteuse on a pas besoin
hi tech n'y a qu'à les laisser comme
elle s'est légèrement
oui j'en ai une deuxième comme ça ça
aussi il paraît que c'était pour la
radio pour rtl non-stop j'ai lu ça dans
un livre parce que j'ai lu tout ce que
tout ce qui devait arriver c'est pour
frédéric françois
il paye vous lui auriez fait croire qu
il y avait une tradition en france
c'était comprenait les empreintes comme
à new york à hollywood
comprenez les empreintes des stars place
de la concorde vous y avez mis le pied
dans le plâtre et s'était filmé la toute
l'équipe fait partie vous avez laissé la
concorde
c'est vrai oui c'était pas place de la
concorde c'est dans un petit coin retiré
sur les bords de la marne et il était
très gentil déjà et donc on lui a mis
les deux pieds dans le dans le plâtre on
a commencé à tourner et puis il ya
quelqu'un de l'équipe technique qui a
dit m et enfants il est midi il faut
aller déjeuner respect mais elle est
plutôt le fruit sa part que donc tout à
fait normal et tout le monde s'est levé
sauf lui puisqu'il est le plâtre
commencé à prendre et on a disparu en
lui disant bas tout à l'heure puis après
le déjeuner et alors il sentait que le
le plâtre gagnait ses chevilles il
aurait bien voulu bouger mais il pouvait
pas il a commencé à appeler au secours
et nous parce qu'on a quand même un
minimum de conscience professionnelle on
l'avait laissé un cadreur pour continuer
à tourner dites moi j'essaye de dentiste
qui est une très bonne idée si les gens
étaient assis un peu tôt identifié six
très bonne idée pour faire des
interviews en plus il y avait une p'tite
[ __ ] je dire je présentais l'émission
seul méga et le montait et descendait
c'était très drôle raviser trouver comme
dans des cités sont très délicates
je parle évidemment de joindre un ailier
et chez les français la wii ah oui là je
jetais au centre d'une bagarre homérique
1 vous saviez que toute manière il ne
s'appréciaient pas l'un à l'autre je
suis comme tous les provocateurs des
ondes quand je réunis des gens qui ne
s'aiment pas c'est généralement
volontairement et ensemble ils s'injurie
rond mais papy viendront aux mains ouais
les seuls qui vous et j'y fais pareil
c'est michel mercier c'est vrai elle m'a
giflé chimie parce que j'avais quand
j'avais répété le propos de son
producteur de l'époque avec qu'elle
venait de se fâcher qui avait dit qu'il
avait davantage de choses dans sa
poitrine que dans son crâne pour iran et
puis
quinze jours plus tard elle s'était
réconcilié avec le producteur et donc
moi elle m'a rencontrée elle mal mal
gifler bon j'ai vu ces photos par la
suite la nature m'a bien revanche bon
alors avant avant de passer aux bouquins
les autres émissions évidemment il y en
a plein à mes 10 ans et le petit théâtre
qui a quand même participé à lancer
mimie mathy laspalès chevalier laurent
baffie gaccio qui est l'auteur principal
six chalets tout d'affilée gaccio comme
moteur principal des guignols a commencé
et smaïn
oui on va avoir un petit bout tout fait
monsieur police contrôle d'identité vous
avez un papier n'ont jamais ses clips
mais bon là ça va il ya quand même
entité la carte d'identité ne l'avait
pas été
voilà la commande était merci vous êtes
algérien oui bon je vois pas en quoi les
autres quarts de travail si la plagne au
travail analogue mes gars de séjour la
carte de séjour merci ça va c'est venu
lacq orthez mon père lacorde pourquoi je
cite ivg la part d'un tambourin pas dans
l'accord date embauche page de la corde
de la carte orange tient donc la corde à
appellation la sécurité sociale à la
corde à linge sur son gain
ça va j'ai pas peiné s'est pas fait mais
déjà là quand j'en attends prix spécial
pour toi monsieur j'ai la carte routière
car on n'est pas des cartons les quatre
voilà l'écart même si opaque oise et non
pas de la carte postale
attendez un petit théâtre de bouvard
alors vous vous dites quand vous parlez
des jeunes gens que vous avez lancée à
l'époque vous dites il y en a même qui
sont reconnaissants non je dis pas ça je
suis plus nuancé jeudi il y en a
quelques-uns qui ne m'en veulent pas
mais à voir et de les poser des
questions vous êtes un vrai je pense à
un frein du chant ou info jean non je
n'ai jamais été méchant que pendant les
heures où on nous payait pour ça fait
comment exactement - faucompret surpris
c'est ce que je vous avais jamais
rencontré et je trouve que c'est évident
des émissions télé chez vous avez un
regard des yeux extrêmement généreux et
pas du tout justement sang froid toute
la générosité bon monsieur
bien alors maintenant je voudrais que
serge khalfon si on peut basculer la
lumière parce que maintenant on va
passer donc parce qu on a dit beaucoup
de bien de vous philippe bouvard voix
basse et olive qui s'appelle joueurs mes
frères qui est chez robert laffont
et maintenant on va passer à votre vie
parce que il a peut-être des yeux
généreux mais ce type là est ambitieux
linda je voulais que les choses soient
dites dès le départ
alors vous avez donc perdu beaucoup
d'argent aux jeux on va y venir vous
avez déclaré le band ce bouquin la seule
façon de tirer profit du jeu quand on
n'est pas casinotier c'est d'écrire un
livre sur le jeu donc j'espère qu'il va
vous rapporter peut-être pas tout ce que
vous avez perdu
non sûrement pas une partie de ce que il
partie de ce que vous avez perdu alors
dans le lit vous expliquer qu'en fait
c'est un héritage familial c'est à dire
que devaux arrière-grands-parents à vos
petits enfants chez les bouvard
tout le monde joue tout le monde tout le
monde tout le monde ce qui fait que mes
mes grands parents et mes parents m'ont
légué la passion du jeu mais seulement
ça quand on sait les rings la zone avant
ces familles là oui et puis j'ai moi
même transmis involontairement mais
parce que il ya la fois le jeu de l'inné
et de l'acquis cette passion à mes
descendants
si je vous aime la transmettrons à
d'autres vous vous jouiez à la belote à
l'âge de 5 ans quand même déjà donc
c'est quand même c'est quand même pas
mal alors votre première partie de poker
j'ai perdu le moins de salaire que vous
n'aviez pas encore touché oui et la
deuxième partie de ce que j'ai fait j'ai
perdu là net salaires qui devaient
commencer l'exercice suivant et renom
mais ça ne laisse pas que des bons
s'ouvrir et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
tout en ne voulant pas brûler ce que
j'ai adoré ce que j'aime encore et tout
en reconnaissant que chaque fois que
j'ai laissé de l'argent dans un casino
j'ai acheté des émotions à nulle autre
pareille
il faut mettre quand même en garde au
moment où il ya une démocratisation de
ce vice car c'est un vice encouragée par
l'état qui trouve son compte
les jeunes et les moins jeunes contre
quelque chose qui est aussi redoutable
ces jeunes la drogue et l'alcoolisme et
des rencontres et des gros joueurs vous
aviez joué avec yves montand le baron
empain j'ai j'ai vu des gros joueurs
et oui par duff parfois comme je vous
vois quelques fois derrière eux en les
regardant jouer
ce sont généralement des spectacles à
yves montand vous dites là dans vsd je
vois que c'était un joueur méchant il
vous entend il ya des joueurs méchant ça
veut dire quoi les gens méchants fâché
non pas du tout ce sont des
alors bon c'était pas que le cas de
montants qu'il y avait eu une brillante
carrière mais il ya des gens qui vous
font payer une table de poker
les déboires qu'ils ont eue dans leur
vie professionnelle ou y arriver ça
c'est affreux et puis d'autres d'autres
qui ont un complexe de supériorité et
qui les pousse après avoir pris leur
argent à quelqu'un qui joue moins bien
que à lui dire tout le mal qu'il pense
de sa façon de jouer en plein patrick
bruel il est comment c'est un très bon
joueur un bon joueur et un bon joueur il
est champion à las vegas meilleur aucoin
quand j'ai lu le bouquin ça m'a rappelé
un noise années 70 j'ai eu beaucoup
d'amis qui étaient accrochées à
l'héroïne qui étaient de jeunes qui je
peux vous dire que quand on est debout
qu'un c'est vraiment une drogue dure
quoi vous dites on joue pas pour gagner
mais pour acheter des émotions fortes et
le le flèche d'adrénaline qu'on n'a rien
fait exactement comme un chou attendait
et l'émotion la plus forte faut quand
même se le savoir sinon comprend rien à
la psychologie du joueur c'est dans la
perte qu'on l'obtient dur vous gagnez
bon vous êtes sur un petit nuage vous
avez plus intelligent que tout le monde
les autres joueurs les casinotiers un
croupier
mais c'est rien ça alors tombé au
complet pas s'est suicidé rennais femme
et ses complices en suisse hier
bien sûr c'est complètement suffirait
comment des parents dit des gens
malheureux tout de vous non mais pour ne
pas les rendre malheureux j'ai travaillé
beaucoup plus que j'avais envie de
travailler et qu'il n'était raisonnable
de travailler parce que quand on a à la
fois un vie c'est une famille à nourrir
faut travailler bout non c'est vrai que
votre niveau de vie vous évite enfin on
le voit même bouquin le misérabilisme
moi j'avais interviewé guy lux qui a
perdu beaucoup d'argent au jeu et qui
m'avait raconté cette anecdote et vous
n'y a pas d'anecdotes aussi aussi dur
dans votre ville à utiliser quand
j'étais jeune mariée la veille de noël
j'ai tout perdu aux cartes et il ne
restait même pas de quoi faire un cadeau
à ma femme à mes enfants j'ai une
histoire quand même à la suite de
laquelle je me suis arrêté de jouer
pendant dix ans un jour jeudi à georges
cravenne que d'un publiciste tout à fait
connu estimable et qui organisait une
partie régulière je le prend à part j
écoute georges cette partie elle
commence à m'inquiéter
lucien morisse s'est donné la mort après
une succession de partie c'est le
directeur artistique d'europe numéro à
la grande époque
anatole litvak est mort le choix d'une
partie sami siritzky est mort après une
partie
bertrand jamal qui est peut-être un
producteur a essayé deux fois de se
suicider il a fait faillite et une des
jeux c'est bien mon vieux mais qu'est ce
que tu veux qu'on fasse d'autres le
samedi 6 mars à risque les frais dans
chaque année nous bouclons hilali
matters vaincre lors il est passé du bon
côté du tapis vert et il est du côté des
casinotiers
oui mais c'est un très grand joueur
comme ça c'est un grand joueur et un
éminent théoricien du black jack
c'est un vieux jeu tourne alors il a
parlé au delà du jeu un petit bout on
vient faire le bilan de vos années de
jeu et de vos activités dans le jeu vous
avez dit comment peut-on avoir écrit au
temps sans avoir écrit une oeuvre quelle
performance et c'est dans un bouquin qui
est là qui vous dit c'est mon premier
livre vous qu'on vous en parle et ça
arrive assez étonnant s'appelle journal
de philippe bouvard
c'est au cherche midi éditeur et là
alors vous êtes d'une d'une franchise
voire d'une crudité avec vous même assez
incroyable j'ai fini par me le pardonner
mais quand je me suis relu la première
fois le vraiment jeté aux galeries la
fâcherie
par exemple vous dites foyer j'ai relevé
trois phrases mais qui sont vraiment
faut avoir le courage d'écrire ça sur
soi même vous êtes un jour je décrirais
par le menu la longue série d'échecs que
peut dissimuler une apparente réussite
bon tout le monde peut le bureau elle
dit mais vous dites
un peu plus loin je suis devenu un de
ces personnages qui me dégoûte est le
plus quand j'avais 20 ans un vieux plein
de fric et de certitudes
il reste les certitudes le fric 120
casino pour perdre se demande si vous
n'êtes pas commander phishing fort
complémentaires si vous écrivez pas ça
pour qu'on vous dise qu'on vous a mis
mon nom j'écris ça parce que
l'autodérision est la seule façon de
désamorcer la dérision c'est bien les
états et de quel signe alors et médite
huit mois une croyance régis quand même
n'a pas du tout pas non non non celle
qu'on veut faire un débat sur
l'astrologie
chili contre elisabeth tiens quand les
deux dernières phrases toujours tirer de
ce livre qui est assez étonnant journal
de boulevard
si j'étais un autre je ne me ferais
compterait pas oui c'est vrai
parce que oui je veux dire j'ai enfin
les relations je suis un autre j'aurais
envie de vous fréquentez quillan sinon
il ya bien bien sûr la chine rpdc
j'ai commencé comme ça alors ok et
gérontophile merci philippe bouvard
on peut rallumer la lumière